foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is
scp-3426 object class
ketter
special containment procedures until the
nature of
scp-3426 can be definitively ascertained
containment should focus on preventing
as many of the theorized conditions for
its occurrence as possible as such
scientific progress into unified physics
hypothesis and the creation of
infinitely sustainable energy should be
heavily impeded other areas of social
and technological progress that could
potentially result in An Occurrence of
scp-3426 on Earth must be prevented by
any reasonable means currently available
additional measures may be taken in the
event that the collective human race
approaches attainment of type 1
civilization status as defined on the
kardashev scale
investigation of phenomena related to
scp-3426 will take place under operation
gray voices mechanical probe surveys to
a maximum range of 100 light years will
attempt to ascertain the commonality and
range of
scp-3426 and demand excursions of post
3426 planets are currently in the
planning process operation gray voices
will centralize the irrelevant collected
data and collaborate with other
Foundation internal research divisions
including the mimetics and info hazards
division temporal anomalies Department
pharmacological department and
biological containment and research
division for the purpose of attaining
Greater understanding of scp-3426
civilian surveys of exoplanets and
cosmological imaging projects will be
strictly monitored for images or data
that show evidence of
scp-3426 upon Discovery data of scp-3426
is to be erased or edited as necessary
and amnestics administered to persons
involved
description
scp-3426 is a phenomenon that is
responsible for the total Extinction of
a technologically and socially Advanced
planetary civilization
scp-3426 may be an event entity process
object or concept to date there exists
no definitive hypothesis on the
attributes of the anomaly however it is
known that the conditions for the
manifestation of
scp-3426 are self-consistent and follow
an established pattern It is believed
that
scp-3426 manifestation is widespread and
possibly Universal
a planet that has been affected by
scp-3426 is termed post 3426 post 3426
planets and civilizations share a number
of common characteristics
the civilization must have achieved a
relative degree of global
socio-political stability
a limitless or indefinitely sustainable
source of worldwide energy is in use for
example nuclear fusion hydrogen mining
orbital solar collection or enhanced
geothermal systems
this energy must be widespread and
plentiful enough for the civilization to
qualify as a type 1 civilization or
higher on the kardashev scale
a unified scientific theory or model of
the universe must have been developed
space travel is commonplace and is
Advanced enough to allow for detailed
exploration of the local solar system
there exists an organization whose
purpose is to catalog and contain as
many anomalous phenomena as possible
post 3426 planets display widespread
anomalous material corrosion reality
Distortion complete or near complete
Corruption of information and
information media and the pervasive
presence of visual Cognito hazards and
abnormalities Sapient life forms on
post-34-26 planets appear in two stages
based on time since
scp-3426 took place if it has been one
year or less since the occurrence of
scp-3426 such organisms appear suspended
or Frozen in place like any
Consciousness and display total cell
death in some cases they may appear
translucent or blurred to cameras and to
the eye afterwards intelligent life is
apparently completely spatially erased
while possessions information and
structures created as a result of the
species remain present if highly
deviated no physical remains of the
species itself exist
data items and artifacts were collected
primarily through the mass usage of
drones orbital probes and imaging
sensors deployed onto post 3426 planets
further information on the exact
Properties or effects of
scp-3426 has been difficult to recover
probes that enter the atmosphere of a
post-3426 planet quickly deteriorate
within 24 hours becoming affected by the
space-time Distortion and material
corrosion permeating the planet's
surface and surroundings as a result
recovered data on post 3426 planets is
extremely Limited
Based on data and related analysis from
operation gray voices It is believed in
that
scp-3426 induces a slow collapse of the
consistency of universal constants and
stable States within the planet this
collapse weakens Force interactions
between Elementary particles creates
Extreme planet-wide Auto kinetic and
material Distortion effects and
gradually prevents any information or
conscious thought from being distributed
this process culminates in all matter on
the planet reaching a state of
catastrophic incoherence theoretically
resulting in the slow Erasure of objects
Concepts and life forms originating from
it this phenomenon has been
provisionally classed as a ZK Lambda
class Cosmic fragmentation scenario
while Research into
scp-3426 has yielded a vast variety of
information regarding its nature and end
results the mechanism by which
scp-3426 acts remains unknown
addendum 3426 1. incomplete list of post
3426 planets
at present operation gray voices has
examined all exoplanets within a 75
light-year radius of Earth from this
current exploration area 16 planets have
met the hypothesized conditions required
for the occurrence of
scp-3426 all 16 were affected by
scp-3426 either upon Discovery or within
five years of detection
a partial list of post 3426 exoplanets
and their characteristics is shown below
gliese 1214b post 3426 2.
traits ocean planet hydrogen and helium
atmosphere dominant life forms were
aquatic non-humanoids with primary
settlements underneath the ocean
technologically advanced society
organized into strict unified social
hierarchies outposts existed both in the
atmosphere and in space used for the
purpose of research into local star
system these civilization had no clear
leader of governmental system rather
computers dispensed resources
distributed according to caste
post 3426 characteristics after
scp-3426 post 3426 2 had approximately
half of its water transmuted into
deuterium and tritium oxide
Consciousness in all Sapient life forms
spontaneously stopped computers and
other data storage devices underwent
apparent Global Information corruption
with only 15 percent of the
civilization's information remaining
readable water molecules no longer flow
the substance acts as a single rigid
continuous solid notes none
Kepler 443 B post 3426 5.
traits fake atmosphere strong
gravitational field and cold average
temperatures dominant life forms had
mammalian characteristics such as body
hair and live birth but possessed
ectothermic circulation in the same
fashion as reptiles dominant religion
involved the worship of an entity
ascribed to the planet's star which was
said to be responsible for continually
rebuilding and moving the universe
post 3426 characteristics post 3426 5
experienced a form of catastrophic
reality degradation in which the
formation of chemical compounds became
impossible due to weakening of the
electrostatic force an additional
anomalous effect causes all Native
living organisms to be perceived as
two-dimensional shimmering gray film
this effect is both present in
phonographs and video from the planet
and physical artifacts collected from it
notes none
gluten B post 3426 10.
traits rocky planet with Earth-like
composition orbiting a red dwarf mild
292 Kelvin temperatures and nitrogen
oxygen atmosphere dominant intelligent
life was humanoid the planet had
recently survived the effects of a
catastrophic nuclear war which
subsequently led to a period of utopian
peace and social stability primary
energy source was obtained through
large-scale drilling into planet's
mantle
post 3426 characteristics all events
taking place on post 34 2610 occur in
apparent disjointed slow motion movement
interaction and even thought are
anomalously decelerated this
deceleration is inconsistent among the
surface with some regions being slower
than others this effect can also
manifest as a complete and total
stopping of time with all particle
movement in an affected region ceasing
analysis of the mantle of the planet
revealed that it had been transformed to
a perfectly smooth transparent layer of
pink glass interaction with the pink
glass results in malfunction of any
nearby electrically powered devices and
intense feeling of vertigo
notes the dominant life forms inhabiting
post
342610 appearing to communicate in an
undocumented Indo-European language with
significant similarities to hittite the
status of this phenomenon as an anomaly
is currently under review
trappist-1f post 3426 13.
traits orbits Ultra cooled dwarf star
Rocky Earth-like composition with large
high pressure water vapor envelope
covering Planet similarly to Earth
planetary Society consisted of a
multitude of separated geopolitical
States coexisting in a roughly
capitalist system analog of the SCP
Foundation notably was a peacekeeping
organization that traded anomalies and
used them strategically to prevent Wars
Research Medical and scientific advances
or expose social and economic injustices
post 3426 characteristics extreme
spatial Distortion entire regions are
displaced from the rest of the surface
while a low static blur is visible
across most of the planet it is unknown
whether this is a visual or ontokinetic
effect on occasion a sudden tear in the
space-time Continuum within the planet's
atmosphere is detected followed by the
appearance of black mist this Mist will
usually move towards an unconscious
sentient life form or data storage
device and enter it once this has been
completed it becomes impossible for any
being to comprehend any concepts related
to or contained in the affected object
this has made data Gathering from post
34 2613 extremely difficult
notes all containment sites operated by
post
342613's SCP Foundation analog have been
replaced by a large spheres of total
darkness mechanical probes entering
these regions of total darkness
experience an unusual form of breakdown
see addendum 3426 3.
addendum 3426 2. recovered data and
artifacts list
rough translations of recovered data
were provided by the Linguistics
Department under request by operation
gray voices translations are not
guaranteed to be accurate
item Source computed Terminal Drive on
Space Station orbiting post 3426 2.
we are on the verge of finally
discovering it
equation for everything the mathematics
is working perfectly two perfectly
perhaps for me to remain comfortable
with this experiment much longer
natural laws behaviors and forces I
cannot help but fear what these findings
imply I cannot keep this secret this
conclusion is something that affects
everything not just on the planet
everywhere
that exists we are and as I stare
further and further into the sand grains
that make this world I am further
convinced that they are built out of
mist and Magic
item Source emergency message found
playing on repeat in all structures in
post 3426 2.
attention or wide informational physical
and chemical hazards please remain calm
and take note of the following
precautions to ensure your safety once
this message completes shut off all
electric devices you currently possess
close all openings or viewings from
outside the building you are currently
in if you are not currently inside an
enclosed building seek shelter in one
immediately cover up or illuminate all
sources of darkness in your location of
shelter destroy any reflective surfaces
in your location of shelter this enjoy
any transparent surfaces in your
location of shelter if you begin
witnessing bizarre disturbing or
unsettling effects occurring in your
location of shelter do not report or
Point them out to any other person doing
so will allow to spread when you begin
to hear the screaming in your mind move
to a room or place where you can be
alone darken the room completely this
will allow the failing to happen most
quickly bring any possessions of
sentimental value with you the screens
will become overpowering do not panic
focus on the memory of great intensity
to you and be silent until you do not
exist if at any point you feel that you
cannot continue remember that a society
issued weapon should be available in
every facility your death will be quick
and painless this message will continue
until nothing is left to hear it this
foreign
item Source a native plant from post
3426 5.
as far as can be ascertained the plant
is approximately 0.5 meters tall and is
most likely a flowering plant this plant
was common across post 3426 5's ground
and was pollinated by many active fauna
on post 3426 5. within the first 15
minutes of viewing the object is
perceived by all intelligent life as a
plant-shaped massive static this static
appears two-dimensional from all sides
despite existing in a three-dimensional
space extended observation of the static
tends to cause discomfort in all
observers after 15 minutes have passed
the plant is no longer able to be
perceived by The Observer the observer's
memories of the plant are immediately
retained but physical viewing of the
plant's location presents itself as the
object itself was not present testers
could describe an unknown object
perfectly even if it was presumably
obscured by the plant this effect
changes after two additional 2 to 3
three days have passed all people who
are affected by the property that
prevents perception of the plants begin
to see the plant as a miscellaneous
flower that the Observer attaches
emotional value or meaning to the flower
type that is perceived varies greatly
from person to person Foundation
artificial intelligence constructs upon
being presented with the plant appear to
perceive it as a random pattern of
shapes and collars the reason for this
effect is undetermined
item Source official internal statement
from the SCP Foundation equivalent from
post 3426 10.
to All That Remain we the conclave of
six reveal our words to you today
because self-signing will soon cease to
exist and it must come to pass because
of our doing we delved too far Knew Too
Much we wanted to know Secrets which
were not meant for The Mortals to know
students of gods and creators
above everything now we Face the
Apocalypse
Divine punishment for our transgressions
we have little left to say in the coming
days you will find that the domain of
physical meaning will shatter into a
billion pieces specifically this planet
will be ravaged both by an by a massive
upheaval in universal laws that is
roughly equivalent to the entire planet
and threat RH phenomenon
and by a vast number of incorporeal
entities we believe they're entities but
we're not sure that will attempt to
slowly erase and corrupt all sources of
information and knowledge originating
from cell signing yes this includes you
you have two choices if you stay on
self-signing your Consciousness will be
ripped apart from you and leave only a
pale image of anything you
time and space will blend their Twisted
forms into each other until everything
and nothing happens at once every second
squished together and lengthened into
eternity communication and thought will
die a slow death eventually everything
that originates from our world will
collapse into itself and be erased from
the universe the only fragments of our
Legacy will be warped to be
unrecognizable
alternatively you can take the
preliminary space shuttle we have made
out of all the anomalous material we
still have left it will get you far but
not much farther from what we understand
it is the very fabric of the Multiverse
itself that is coming to plot us out
long live self-signing
man's death not be in vain
item Source handwritten node scrolled
into the inside back cover of a book on
post 3426 13.
the world is on slow fire swarms of
bitter void break apart from the sky and
attack I don't think there's time left
to escape I think even if we did they
would follow
I looked upwards and in a moment the sky
was suddenly black and the sun was even
darker all filaments and strands of
infectious Shadows I don't even know how
they got here why they chose art why why
they sent sent the flying things signals
I can't recall the names
doesn't hit the black barrier they
simply
had disappeared
we are going away too everything I know
is fading I look at the world and half
of the words I use for things have been
blocked out by my memory
the computers don't work anymore when I
open this book the words are replaced by
bars of white and black and that's what
they're doing don't you see they are
nothing but nothing and they want to
make us unreal into time and space
unreal
as I look out of this window the top
half of the building next to me is
disjointed from the bottom half the
people in the window across are frozen
then they Flash and move for an instant
and are frozen once more every time they
move the color of everything turns red
and blue and green in a strobe of Terror
reality is coming apart at the seams
I have
my sister is in the house with me we are
trying to keep Out Of Reach of the
unreal Darkness
she's she has told me that there is a
voice in her head I asked her what the
voice was saying she said it was only a
wailing it
it's the end for her then I will watch
as the Wailing overpowers our mind
and she forgets everything she is
she will forget she was ever in
intelligent being
she will forget all of the world and all
of the past in the present and the
future the little of it we have left
she will then become unregisterable to
me in my mind or to anyone's mind
her Consciousness and her identity will
be severed from the rest of our
knowledge
he dissolves alone in a universe of one
and becomes an object eaten by the
all-consuming unreality
I'm too young
[Music]
I I hear something in my head
the light
level 4
3426 classified
addendum 3426 3 post 34 26 13
exploration log
exploration log 3426 UA 13c
the following log depicts the received
camera feed of the exploration of the
Void regions of post 3426 13 involving
the usage of an unmanned drone this file
is limited to Personnel level 4
clearance or higher while neither info
hazards nor Cognito hazards have yet
been detected to be present in this
transcription all Personnel viewing this
file must undergo a level 2 hazardous
meme scan before proceeding
in order to investigate the widespread
regions of void present across post
342613 the scps sternulict and unmanned
exploration vessel drops out of FTL in
the upper atmosphere of post-34 2613 the
sternal light simultaneously launches a
close range automated drone
skf-70 with camera feed connected to the
main ship
playing log now t plus 127 the Drone
enters the lower atmosphere and deploys
parachute drone registers minus surface
damage later analysis shows that a thin
layer of material surrounding the Drone
had been transformed into balsa wood
cause of this event is unknown
t plus 450 the Drone lands on the
surface of post 34 26 13. video feed
shows that the sky appears to be phasing
in and out making formations such as
clouds and the sun periodically look
transparent the sky is a pinkish red
color with a dark Hue caused by the low
brightness of the red dwarf star
trappist-1 a number of avian life forms
appear to be frozen in the sky
T Plus 501 drone begins movement towards
point of Target from its altitude the
camera can see the regional landscape
the area appears to be a coastal
grassland plain ocean water drifts
towards the shoreline in misshapen
angular waves as the waves break onto
the beach they are suddenly turned into
what are apparently perfectly cut
diamonds the diamonds Fade Away seconds
after they are deposited on the beach
camera pans 180 degrees a number of
vaguely humanoid life forms are frozen
in place along the shore thin white
wisps evaporating of their forms debris
is strewn about the area and small fires
burn in the distance
t plus o5 11. abruptly there is a flash
on the camera feed that blinds The View
momentarily after a few seconds The View
returns revealing that the entire Sky
appears to have lost all color contrast
there is a crackling noise and the color
of the sky returns to normal drone
begins heading towards the Target
location
D plus 1408 drone passes over the
planet's surface for approximately four
kilometers video feed notes the
appearance of several more anomalous
features several structures and
buildings appear to be completely
flattened into the ground creating
two-dimensional images of the structures
and their contents on the surface the
Drone passes by a number of posters
Billboards and other signage however all
words and iconography on the signs
appear as unreadable black bars many of
the objects flora and fauna on post 34
2613 are warped or disjointed in some
way and some are translucent or nearly
transparent
t plus 1735 drone approaches Target
camera shows a completely dark sphere
completely static emitting no sound or
light the sphere is roughly estimated to
be about a quarter mile in radius drone
activates several sensors to scan
anomaly including light sound sentience
matter scattering and conceptual
identity all sensors return negative
t plus 1759 drone breaches the barrier
of the Void
t plus 1836 camera feed begins to play
faint sounds of static a pristine
non-anomalous planetary landscape is
seen about 50 yards ahead there is an
industrial building with large glass
windows and unreadable Insignia branded
on the front door enters an Open Door on
the first floor of the complex
the plus 1855 static slightly increases
in volume drone emerges in a clean
bluish white office space with large
plastic counter on the far side
decorated with potted plants a sign is
hung on the back of the wall behind the
counter normally this sign would be a
legible or obscured by sensory bars
however there are words on the sign
reading nothing is here lock yourself
inside
t plus 21 40. drone proceeds down open
Corridor to one side there are large
glass windows open to Sky as the Drone
continues down the corridor the windows
appear to grow and shrink in dimension
there is a small object at the end of
the corridor which terminates in a dead
end the corridor is not lit well enough
for the object to be identified
t plus 22 23 set onto the floor of the
corridor is what is evidently a
television set the television has the
same shape and dimensions to match a
typical CRT television from the late
1970s as the Drone approaches it turns
on
t plus 22 31 the Drone stops despite the
control systems from the stern elect
being completely severed the sound of
starting on the video feed suddenly
increases in volume nearly drowning out
any other noise the television shows a
series of sounds and images including
clips of asteroids floating through
space large networks of massive
supercomputers crowds of people going
about their daily activities the Drone
itself hovering in front of the
television screen and an endless
brightly lit Corridor these images cycle
through each other interspersed with
flashes of white light the cycling
becomes faster than the flashes of light
last longer and longer faintly visible
in the light now are outlines of shapes
amorphous forms that move about the
screen the amorphous forms combine and
reform until they create the vague
outline of a human head the human head
is looking directly into the drone's
camera
t plus 24 57 the Drone is suddenly
propelled forward towards a collision
course with the blank wall the wall
appears to fall away and the Drone is
pushed forward into an empty white space
and begins to fall
t-plus 34 57 after exactly 10 minutes of
continuous falling the Drone suddenly
emerges in the office lobby at the
entrance of the building the lobby is
nominally the same in organization
appearance and features the sign behind
the counter is changed words it now
reads go back to sleep go back to sleep
go back outside the floor-to-ceiling
windows the entire sky has acquired a
dull red glow
t plus
3709 the camera notes the presence of a
new hallway to the other side of the
previous hallway that was not present
before as the Drone approaches faint
sounds of mechanical operation such as
electrical beeps and running Motors
become fatally audible just as the Drone
is about to enter the hallway the video
feed suddenly emits the sound of
screaming and the Drone appears again in
the center of the office foyer for
approximately two hours the Drone
continuously attempts to enter the newly
made hallway with the same events
occurring each time
t plus 232 32 over the next two hours
the sun sets and night falls there is a
knocking on the windows but no movement
is registered from the outside the
knocking on the Windows becomes more and
more frantic from the outside the stars
appear to be blood red the Drone
approaches the hallway and this time is
not impeded the starter in the
background swells and crackles and a
faint voice can be made out just
underneath the interference the voice
says the universe is an infinite
staircase but it is shattered you will
shatter it the Drone proceeds down the
hallway
t plus 2 3815 the hallway is an endless
brightly lit Corridor with no exits or
side doors fluorescent lights are
positioned on the ceiling at regular
intervals after a few minutes of travel
it is impossible to tell how far the
Drone has moved the featurelessness of
the hallway prevents any kind of
relative positioning t plus 3 50 49
after about one hour of travel the
static slowly begins to quiet and is
replaced with the growing sound of
high-pitched whaling coming from
thousands of sources
t plus 401 50. dark wisps are emitted
from the lamps swarming together and
flowing through the air the audio is
interspersed with intense high frequency
sound when the sound is emitted the
video feed suddenly pixelates and shows
random patterns of vivid colors this
pattern continues for a little less than
two days
t plus 51 3704 a subtle change is now
added to this pattern of data every time
a pixelation event occurs one of the
pixels in the camera remains dead
sticking to the camera screen over time
the dead pixels fill the entire camera
view
t plus 78 2330 the video feed has now
been completely obscured by a variety of
dead pixels the sound of screaming has
reached approximately 150 decibels
intense enough to cause rupturing of the
eardrums shapes appear to form in the
dead pixels as if the pixels were moving
through a field or an outline of static
the hallway shape is vaguely visible in
the static as the Drone continues to
move through it but now visible are
hundreds of distorted human figures that
stand still in the hallway extending
indefinitely through the corridor their
faces featureless except for eyes and a
mouth
t plus 78 25 41 The High Frequency
pitches cease the audio feed is now
completely silent
t plus 78 25 48 the swarm of humanoid
faces all simultaneously turned towards
the drone's camera the figures
disintegrate into black minute particles
the pixelation effect and the camera
clears the lights in the hallway all go
out leaving the Drone in complete
darkness
t plus 78 25 53 the Drone activates its
Searchlight and shines it into the
hallway the hallway begins to spin and
reflect in on itself different sections
of the hallway seem to cross over each
other rotate and reverse until it
creates a kaleidoscope-like pattern in
place of the original Corridor the
hallway splits in half repeatedly into
sections separated by cracks of blinding
white light the hallway then appears to
unravel and coil itself around the probe
until it has no room left to move the
cracks in the hallway expand and the
light spilling out of it grows brighter
t plus 78 26 36 the camera view switches
abruptly to a continuous White Field
t plus 84 1147 nearly six hours later
changes detected in the camera view the
White Field begins to gradually Fade
Into total Blackness as this occurs
systems on the Drone progressively shut
down in sequence and the probe begins to
lose capabilities
t plus 84 1421 the Drone shakes
violently as its processing systems
completely fail a dark red flashes
briefly seen permeating the camera's
view before the feed cuts out
end log
addendum
the transcription of this camera feed is
based on General consensus from a
variety of viewers of the drone's camera
recordings the accuracy or reality of
this transcription is currently not
known re-recordings or attempts at
computer analysis of this exploration
log indicate that all reception ends
past timestamp t plus 1759 past this
point the recording apparently consists
entirely of static
this was a a strange SCP
the notion of completely erasing a
planet's Legacy and identity and memory
that is truly malevolent
man I suppose that concludes today's
lecture thank you for listening if you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to anvil
zargaran
Professor Puffer
retalias
givios the hollow
zazapan
Jordan C Wilde
Lemke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
perpetually confused meet Mac pilot
segnar
Kai lacks empathy
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Gabriel Hawkins
knit the Klein
Lost Boy
a real American Hebrew
demnadus
the Morrigan
and James Saba if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgan
thank you